it's michelle of lab muffin beauty
science chemistry phd cosmetic chemist
and professional sunscreen video maker i
have talked a ton about sunscreen over
the years
but i found that on every sunscreen
video i get asked questions that i've
answered in another video and i think
it's because i've gotten a lot of new
followers so hi welcome and thank you so
i thought i'd do a video where i tried
to cover every sunscreen question that's
relevant to wearing sunscreen which i
realized four and a half thousand words
into the script is
a very lofty goal and i'm sure the
moment i published this video i'll think
of three more so here is almost all your
sunscreen questions answered like and
subscribe so you don't miss out on me
answering those three questions that i
forgot about i've done tons of videos
and blog posts on sunscreen i also have
an ebook that has a sunscreen chapter so
i'll be summarizing a lot of things i'll
put links to the more detailed
explanations in the description so
please check that before you send me
comments saying i'm talking out my let's
get into it when do i need to wear
sunscreen i'm not your mum so you don't
need to do anything
however these are the official
australian guidelines which are a
collaboration between experts from
dermatology as well as from
endocrinology bone health and cancer the
world health organization has similar
guidelines as well and they're meant to
balance the health risks and the
benefits of sun exposure so skin cancer
versus the benefits which is mostly
vitamin d production they recommend that
when the uv index is three or above in
the middle of the day you should use sun
projection if you go outside for more
than a few minutes even with sun
protection you'll probably still produce
enough vitamin d when the uv index is
below 3 then sun protection is not
recommended and they recommend that you
go outdoors in the middle of the day
with uncovered skin on most days now
these guidelines are very general and
it's just for skin cancer risk so
wearing sunscreen when the uv index is
through or above is sort of like bare
minimum stuff and the evidence points
towards sunscreen specifically not
making that much of a difference when it
comes to vitamin d production all the
little bits of your body that don't get
covered in enough sunscreen will make
vitamin d when you're in the sun anyway
so if you're trying to improve your skin
and deal with skin concerns like acne
uneven pigment premature aging so fine
lines and wrinkles which i'm guessing
you are since you're watching this video
then you probably should wear sunscreen
on your face every day if you're going
outside the sun's uv is the biggest
preventable cause of skin aging and
pigmentation prevention is much easier
and more effective than trying to undo
the damage later and it's usually
cheaper as well this is especially the
case when it comes to deeper damage that
you need procedures to tackle and not
just skin care if you're not wearing
sunscreen it means that your skincare
products have to work harder to get
results it's like they're swimming
upstream against the current so if you
use sunscreen to block out a bunch of
that uv stop some of that current in
this analogy then your products will be
able to work better there's actually a
study that found that skin texture
clarity and pigmentation improved with
just wearing sunscreen daily so your
skin has the ability to repair itself if
you cut down the amount of uv smashing
into it sunscreen is especially
important if you're using skincare
products with alpha hydroxy acids like
glycolic and lactic acids
these chemical exfoliants actually make
your skin more sensitive to uv so if
you're not wearing sunscreen as well it
can actually mean your anti-aging
skincare is making your skin age faster
which is really rude what should i look
for in a sunscreen basically all it
comes down to is is it protective enough
for what you're doing and is it
comfortable and budget friendly enough
that you'll wear enough of it so let's
start with protection the most important
thing is spf spf tells you how well the
sunscreen protects against burning which
is mostly to do with shorter wavelengths
of uv called uvb these are also the most
damaging rays of uv as well as burning
they cause skin cancer and premature
skin aging higher spf is better the
protection you get is proportional to
that spf number that's why spf ratings
were designed the way they are the whole
spf 30 already protects against 97 of uv
is a myth for most people spf 30 is
enough for an everyday sunscreen but you
might want high protection if you're
getting a lot of sun or if you just want
higher protection the downside of higher
spf is that the formulas can be a bit
thicker and less nice to wear but this
has been improving a lot in the last
five years
uva projection is also important uva
refers to the longer lower energy
wavelengths of uv that cause less
burning but they're still linked to skin
aging cancers and increased pigment
production
uva protection is a bit trickier than
spf because there isn't really a
universally agreed upon way of measuring
uva protection and some countries like
australia actually don't let brands show
more detailed uva protection numbers
there are a lot of different labels used
in different places so i'm just going to
show a summary on screen and you can
check my uva video for more info
basically you want to go for at least
broad spectrum if you care a lot about
hyperpigmentation or premature aging
you'll want to look for higher uva
protection water resistance is the final
special sunscreen label that's regulated
it tells you how much spf protection is
left after sitting in water for a
particular amount of time in general
more water resistant sunscreens are also
more resistant to other things like
sweat sand rubbing and movement so it's
a good idea to use water resistant
sunscreen if you're obviously getting
into the water but also if you're just
moving around a lot while getting sun
exposure water resistance is a bit
tricky because different regions have
different rules even though the label is
the same australia and the us have the
strictest ones now if you have darker
skin so if it's patrick four or above
and you're worried about pigmentation
you might want to use a tinted sunscreen
to protect against visible light from
the sun physical sunscreens without a
tint aren't very good for this and
tinted chemical sunscreens work about as
well as tinted physical sunscreens it's
really just about that tint tinted
sunscreens aren't really regulated for
visible light protection so it's hard to
say which one is best foundation
probably works great for this as well
aside from protection it's really just
personal preference with things like
texture white cast skin sensitivity and
cost you need a sunscreen that you enjoy
enough to apply regularly and that you
can afford to apply regularly because
you do need to apply quite a bit of
sunscreen texture is incredibly
important and i think quite underrated
these days there are lots of really
nicely textured sunscreens that give
great protection they can feel just like
primal or moisturizer if a sunscreen has
a texture that you hate it's more likely
to just sit on the shelf unused and
you're less likely to apply enough of it
there's a lot of talk about chemical
versus physical sunscreens but they're
actually really similar and the things
that i've already mentioned are way more
important my very general rule of thumb
is if your biggest problem with
sunscreen is texture or white cast i
would recommend trying a chemical
sunscreen first but if your biggest
problem is irritation then i would
recommend trying a physical sunscreen
first there are also combination
sunscreens which have a mix of chemical
and physical filters they tend to be
somewhere in between the two for texture
and white cast i personally use a few
different categories of sunscreen for
different situations i have everyday
sunscreens that are light and
comfortable they sit really nicely under
makeup and they don't clog my pores that
much for me these have to be above spf
30 they have to have good uva protection
and i prefer newer filters that are less
irritating to my skin and eyes i also
have hardcore face sunscreens that i use
for outdoor activities when i don't
really care how i look and sun
protection is really that priority these
are spf 50 plus broad spectrum and water
resistant i also have hardcore
sunscreens for my body for outdoor
activities these are also spf 50 plus
broad spectrum and water resistant but
also relatively cheap so i'm not tempted
to apply less to save money ideally
these also work for my face so i don't
have to mess around with two bottles
when it's time to reapply i have a video
with my favorite sunscreens from last
year and i've added a few to the list
since then these are all in the
description
how much sunscreen do i apply to get the
spf on the label you have to apply two
milligrams per square centimeter which
works out to be a bit less than a
quarter teaspoon for just your face for
most people since the amount you need
depends on your face size the actual
amount will be a bit different for
everyone you can try to measure your
face but it is a bit of effort so if in
doubt just aim for a quarter teaspoon
you might have heard of using two
fingers of sunscreen obviously the
amount depends a lot on how thick your
lines are so if you're not sure you can
try scraping your lines into a quarter
teaspoon measure the reason you have to
apply so much is that your skin is bumpy
so if you don't apply enough then the
sunscreen sits in the valleys on your
skin and the heels don't get covered or
the layer just ends up way too thin a
little goes a long way just doesn't work
with sunscreen it's like a paint that
you're wearing to hide your skin from
the sun if you don't have enough paint
on then parts of your skin will be
exposed for the rest of your body there
are a lot of different recommendations
for how much you need to apply because
different places use different estimates
for different sized people and chances
are your proportions don't match the
ones they calculated for so when in
doubt just apply more than you need my
favorite version is the cancer council
version because i think it's the easiest
one to memorize it's one teaspoon for
each of these parts how do i actually
apply sunscreen now for actually
applying it i think it's really helpful
to remember that sunscreen works best
when it's in a smooth even undisturbed
layer so with that in mind it probably
makes the most sense to put sunscreen on
your skin after skin care regardless of
what type of sunscreen it is chemical
sunscreens don't need to absorb into
bare skin to activate and work the only
exception is if it's a special type of
long wear sunscreen that's meant to
absorb into your skin those usually form
a film in the top of your skin so you
probably don't want tons of skin care
under or over it use your skincare a few
hours earlier try to make sure the
sunscreen is evenly spread over your
skin you can dab it onto the different
parts of your face at the start you
don't want to rub too much there's a
study showing that rubbing reduces
protection so apply it evenly and then
let it dry down don't rub it in the
whole time you should also apply all
sunscreens before you go outside
sunscreens don't need time to activate
but they do need time to settle down and
not get wiped off onto your clothes or
get disturbed by too much moving it's a
lot like wet paint the recommendation is
usually 15 minutes but it depends on the
sunscreen in one study the sunscreen
they used only needed eight minutes
how do i apply sunscreen when i'm also
wearing skincare and makeup sunscreen
makes the most sense in between skincare
and makeup so your skincare can sink
into your skin and not mess up your
sunscreen and so your sunscreen doesn't
mess up your makeup again i think it's
really helpful to remember that
sunscreen works best when it's in a
smooth even undisturbed layer there
aren't a lot of studies done on wearing
sunscreen with other products but based
on studies for other situations it seems
like anything under the sunscreen but
especially on top of the sunscreen can
mess up your sunscreen layer so try to
minimize the amount of skincare you're
using under the sunscreen so keep it to
one or two products and minimize the
makeup that you use on top of the
sunscreen again try to wait for the
sunscreen layer to flatten down and
stick to your skin before you apply your
makeup maybe 5-10 minutes and try to
apply your makeup as gently as possible
it's also probably best to use the
sunscreen with a higher spf than you
need so if it drops from the makeup then
you'll still be getting the spf you want
how can you stop sunscreen from balling
up when sunscreen balls up it's usually
a interacting with your skincare b
drying too fast or c you're rubbing it
too much so you can try a applying it on
bare skin
b applying on a massively moisturized
skin or c patting it on gently
unfortunately my skin is really oily and
sometimes my own face oil is actually
what's making it ball up and people with
dry skin have no problems with the same
sunscreen so if you've tried the above
and none of that worked i would just try
a different sunscreen i found so many
that work well on my skin even though i
think i have a really bald prone skin
type how do i look less shiny with
sunscreen on a lot of sunscreens are
oily because a lot of sunscreen actives
are oils or dissolved in oils so if you
blot away the oil you're probably going
to remove some sunscreen as well the
best way i've found to reduce shine
without lowering the protection too much
is to wait for the sunscreen to set and
then gently pat on some translucent
powder on top i really like starch based
powders for this and this can also soak
up any extra oil that i produce during
the day and i would also recommend just
looking for a less shiny sunscreen to
buy the next time can i use blank
instead of sunscreen you might have some
products that say spf on them and you're
wondering if you can use them instead of
sunscreen the answer is usually no the
main thing to remember is you need to
apply about a quarter teaspoon to your
face and some products just don't really
work that way for applying that much
foundation with spf this is what you
look like when you apply the proper
amount i usually apply about 1 8 of this
a very sheer foundation might
potentially work but i haven't found one
that doesn't do
this powder with spf it just doesn't
stick to your skin enough this is what
it looks like when you apply the right
amount the powder that works best is
probably the color science powder that's
designed for this but even then their
evidence doesn't really convince me that
you can apply enough things that do work
moisturizer with spf if you can apply
the right amount this depends on the
moisturizer texture but in terms of the
formula sunscreens are the same as
moisturizers with spf they just chose a
different name to put on the label body
sunscreens
yes you can use body sunscreens on your
face and face sunscreens on your body
the only minor issue is that body
products tend to spread more easily and
be a bit heavier but if you're fine with
that then it's fine uv protective
clothing is fantastic but obviously some
skin is usually uncovered regular
clothes can work as well depending on
the fabric hats and umbrellas are useful
but most of the uv you get actually gets
bounced from the sky rather than coming
directly from the sun so the lower parts
of your face actually get a lot less
protection so these are good to use in
conjunction with sunscreen to add extra
layers of protection think of it like
layers of swiss cheese layering enough
types of imperfect protection will give
you pretty good protection overall can i
mix sunscreen with foundation or
moisturizer or another sunscreen it's
best not to mix sunscreens with any
other products even though it can make
it feel nicer or get rid of white casts
or make your routine faster it changes
the way the sunscreen dries which can
mean you get holes in your protection
sunscreens are emulsions like mayonnaise
if you have the wrong proportions then
the emulsion can break and separate if
you've ever seen how foundation can
bunch up if you apply it over the wrong
product the same thing can happen to
sunscreen and if that's happening on a
microscopic level you won't be able to
spot it and stop doing it it's best to
just look for a sunscreen that already
does what you want if you don't want
white cast then go for a chemical
sunscreen if you want a tin then go for
tinted sunscreen even worse are those
sunscreen drop products that you're
meant to mix into a moisturizer to make
your own sunscreen this means that you
have this holy film issue plus you end
up applying so little of it that you end
up with really low spf can i make my own
diy sunscreen so i mentioned the
sunscreen drop products that you mix
into other products end up with really
low protection and unreliable film
formation there are also diy sunscreen
recipes that involve mixing zinc oxide
powder or diaper cream into oils or
moisturizers to get around 20 zinc oxide
which matches the percentage in a
store-bought sunscreen this doesn't work
because protection isn't about the
percentage of the active ingredients
it's also about how they're distributed
in the sunscreen and how that applies on
the skin sunscreen uses special grades
of zinc oxide with very small particles
this makes it absorb more uv and it can
also cover a larger area even with 20 of
this special zinc oxide mixed with
industrial equipment that can make the
zinc oxide spread out more evenly in the
sunscreen sunscreen formulators still
get low spf sometimes this is because
the base isn't keeping that zinc oxide
spread out properly when you apply it to
your skin so sunscreen formulators can't
get consistently high spf with all of
this special stuff the chance of you
getting it right consistently at home
with the wrong kind of zinc oxide is
not great
can i use expired sunscreen there's no
guarantee the sunscreen will be working
after the expiry date so i would
recommend throwing expired sunscreen out
also don't store sunscreen in the heat
it can break down and separate even
before it expires which means you won't
get even protection so don't store it in
your car glovebox and if you're at the
beach or at the park try to keep it in
the shade do i need to reapply sunscreen
the main reason you need to reapply
sunscreen is that the sunscreen layer
gets less even over time like foundation
the sunscreen layer clumps up over time
because your skin is moving and
producing sweat and oil underneath that
means you'll start getting tiny gaps in
your sunscreen layer that the uv can get
through some of the sunscreen also
evaporates into the air and absorbs into
your skin so that sunscreen layer will
get thinner and less effective sunscreen
can also get wiped off onto things and
if you wet the sunscreen layer that can
also clump up even if it's a water
resistant sunscreen so after you've had
your sunscreen on for two hours you're
probably not getting that label
protection anymore which is an issue if
you're about to get more sun exposure
important note this is two hours of the
sunscreen being on your skin not two
hours of sun exposure there's this
misconception that reapplying sunscreen
is because the sunscreen ingredients
stop working after absorbing two hours
of sun this is a myth most sunscreens
are pretty photo stable now so the
ingredients almost always keep working
for longer than the sunscreen film takes
to clump up this two hours is also just
a general rule there's evidence that
some sunscreens can last a lot longer
and obviously if you're sweating or
moving around a lot and your sunscreen
isn't water resistant it probably won't
be staying put if you aren't moving
around a lot then you probably still
have pretty decent protection after a
few hours but no one's tested the
protection for a wide range of sunscreen
so it's really hard to say how much and
unfortunately you can't really rely on
what you see with a uv camera uv cameras
don't have enough resolution to tell
what's going on and they work on uva
only one study found that the uv photo
looked exactly the same even with around
15 less spf how do i reapply sunscreen i
think reapplying sunscreen on your body
is pretty straightforward but how do you
reapply it on your face
and how do you do it if you're wearing
makeup unfortunately there isn't really
a perfect way to get high protection
while keeping your makeup intact so i
approach it depending on how much sun
exposure i'm going to get afterwards
situation one is if i'm getting a lot of
sun exposure say i'm going on a long
beach walk in the afternoon then i keep
my makeup simple and just reapply the
full amount of sunscreen like normal
every two hours followed by minimal
makeup you don't have to wash off your
sunscreen you can just reapply on top
but if there's dirt on your face or if
it's just getting a bit messy you can
wipe it off before you reapply situation
two is if i'm getting some sun and i
want to keep my makeup mostly intact say
it's summer and i'm walking outside for
20 minutes after work then i reapply
sunscreen on top of my makeup right
before i go out there are only really
true options for this that i think give
enough protection the option i prefer is
reapplying a light regular sunscreen
over my makeup i use a cushion puff
which is a method that jude of 50 shades
of snail came up with around 2015. i
really love these because they're so
thin they're really portable and they
don't absorb much sunscreen it is still
good to use a bit more sunscreen than
normal to make up for what ends up in
the sponge there are sunscreen cushions
from asian brands as well that are
designed for reapplying over makeup but
i find those too expensive plus they
usually have a white cast the other
option that can give decent coverage is
a spray sprays can get into the valleys
of your skin but the main issue is that
sprays can be a bit light in some spots
so you need to make sure you apply
enough layers so if you're using a spray
make sure you apply enough layers let
each layer dry down before you apply the
next layer
you can spray your spray into a quarter
teaspoon measure to work out how many
sprays you need the other issue is that
breathing in too much sunscreen probably
isn't very good for you so if you use a
spray make sure you hold your breath and
walk out of the cloud of spray before
you breathe in again also be careful if
it's too windy because the spray just
won't land on your skin i would also
avoid aerosol sunscreens the spf test is
usually done before adding propellant so
you need to apply a lot more to get that
label protection for reapplication it's
always safe is to go with a sunscreen
that has similar active ingredients to
what you're already wearing there's a
slight chance that the sunscreen actors
can react with each other and break down
if you aren't mixing them around a lot
then it shouldn't be a huge problem but
it is safest to try to avoid that anyway
situation three is when i get minimal
sun so for example i'm going outside for
five minutes and it's mostly shady in
that case i don't reapply i rely on what
i have on already and just try to stay
in the shade you can also use those
layers of protection so hats shades
sunglasses umbrellas are great if you
don't think your reapplication was quiet
enough and also just generally when
you're getting a lot of sun can i
transfer sunscreen into a different
container i would really recommend not
doing that especially not for a long
time a lot of sunscreen ingredients can
react with or soak into some plastics
this means you can end up with less
active ingredients in the sunscreen and
the sunscreen can dry in weird ways on
your skin glass should be okay if it's
very clean and if you keep it protected
from light
how do i deal with eye sting some
sunscreens can sting your eyes and
annoyingly it seems to be different
ingredients and sunscreens for different
people there are some sunscreens out
there that don't sting your eyes much so
look at reviews for those but if you
found the perfect sunscreen apart from
my sting you can use a different
sunscreen for around your eyes i like to
use a zinc oxide sunscreen stick because
they tend to stay put for longer and
zinc oxide tends to not make your eyes
water some people also find that setting
their sunscreen with translucent powder
helps but
that isn't quite enough for me do i need
to wear sunscreen indoors
probably not you probably aren't getting
enough uv inside your house window glass
blocks almost all the uvb but uva can
still come through and that can
potentially cause premature aging and
increase pigment but the roof and the
walls are probably blocking the vast
majority of it unless you have sunlight
directly hitting your skin through a
window or if you're sitting next to a
big window and you can see lots of sky
through it monitors and phone screens
don't produce enough damaging light to
worry about unless you have a special
condition and you would know if you have
one of these fluorescent lights also
don't produce much uv if they're
properly shielded maybe be careful if
you have a bare bulb particularly an
older curly bulb there are a lot of
other myths about sunscreen that i
haven't covered here and i'm sure
there'll be even more to come but here
is a list of myths that i've debunked
before i've linked the long versions in
the description but here is my attempt
to speedrun the more common ones in 20
words or less each chemical sunscreens
are dangerous hormonal disruptors legal
limits based on all relevant data in
context with large margin of safety
fear-mongering sites show select studies
only nanoparticles are dangerous
nanoparticles don't penetrate beyond the
stratum corneum with unbroken skin
chemical and physical sunscreens work
differently
both mostly work the same only five to
ten percent uv is scattered by physical
sunscreens the rest is absorbed physical
sunscreens work better how well
sunscreen works depends on spf and uv
apf chemical sunscreens can get higher
spfs and uv apfs heat from chemical
sunscreens is bad for melasma chemical
and physical sunscreens produce around
same heat that amount is undetectable
some sunscreens aren't reef safe climate
change agricultural pollution
overfishing are killing reefs way too
little sunscreen and ocean to make a
difference sunscreens contain
carcinogenic benzene and mounts in
sunscreen are tiny you get more from
parking your car in a garage attached to
your house if i didn't answer something
in enough detail i've probably covered
it in a different video i've done a lot
of sunscreen videos and blog posts and
instagram posts if you want more
practical specifics about finding and
using sunscreen and setting up a
skincare routine check out my ebook if
you're a sunscreen nerd the sunscreen e
summit is coming up it's a free
conference on may 15th hosted by me and
jen of the ecowell we've locked in talks
from some of the top sunscreen experts
in the industry i'll be talking about
sunscreen myth busting it is going to be
an incredible event so make sure you
book in for that and check out more
videos from me coming up on the side
here